i've seen you before at out at our our
secret meetings
oh and i don't and but i don't approach
why because that's weird and we also
don't want to betray
the higher calling of what that is all
right so this guy's awesome can we talk
about
how how much are you willing to talk
about that oh i just wrote a book about
all of it
all right yeah yeah and when you see the
secret group because people can we talk
about what that is
yeah so um you know i've been
hanging around at the la a scene for
i don't know over 20 years you know um
and so you'd seen me when i at an a
meeting yeah and you never said what's
up i'm josh i just felt weird i i just
felt weird because i knew i would listen
to the show and i also like whenever
anyone's public i make sure to stay far
away because i see how much they're
getting hit up yeah and so i just want
to be like if at all i can be of help
sometime down the road it'll happen the
thing i noticed about you would be you
you have a quick you have a quick little
get up when you walk
but what if he wouldn't be i know he
already means what do you mean
you don't want to talk to anyone oh like
after what oh when the meeting's done
yeah yeah
what's your thought process behind that
when you get up cool
oh my god that's so funny it makes me
laugh so much because it is something
that i do head down going yeah yeah
quick gate
okay okay okay all right all right all
right so there's a million
all right so i'll just give you an
example okay
saturday janina gavankar who i did a
movie with last year right
so she keeps inviting me to things you
know what i mean like i'm in town for a
couple of days i have lo you know i'm
always busy
so she goes um three weeks ago
she texted me there's a congressman uh
something tanaka mark tanaka or
something and he's um
you know he's doing some sort of um
event
in silver lake do you want to go and i
just rapidly read it and go i you
flagged on yeah right so then like
two days before the event she texted me
oh here it is
and now i have to go and i read on it
and i have to donate money to even go
right right so there's like a platinum
ticket and another thing and the
platinum ticket's like 500 bucks
i gotta go right so i pay you help me
buy the ticket right
and i show up and it's literally like
30 people in a small little courtyard
and i'm sitting there i don't know
anything about him i know anything about
politics i don't know why i'm there and
i'm seeing people with rich people are
there with suits
and i'm sitting there and you know
people are asking everyone's asking
questions
so um congressman when you you propose
that you know that article you know i
mean in front of the congress why did
someone you know i mean and
you i'm like what is going on i don't
know if he's a republican i don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on here right and
so i just kind of go i got to go and i
ran out while he's talking you crossed
him i crossed him oh my god
and the reason and i did that walk
[Laughter]
how long were you there
a couple hours oh okay yeah because i
saw other people leaving too yeah right
so i'm like oh you can leave
i don't know so i did that so i did that
in two with reason and janine i had a
great time and it was a fun and i i
suppose your exits even though you're
gonna with a quick gate as you say
they're never that discreet it's like he
thinks he's moving fast
and like i thought
what do you mean like i'm sure you cr
you know you took the route where you
knew you had to cross him in front of
the whole crowd
could you go to the back don't lie okay
ah all right all right
people have to know i'm leaving
all right why be there
number one irish goodbye
he's like bye but i'm not gonna say
anything
yeah so i left for two years i was
uncomfortable yeah i learned a lot
and then also secondly um
there's a valet
only one guy working gotta go right
gotta design somebody's house
and you think to yourself
there's 35 people here right the
apparently all bad valet right
if we i go with the group i'm there for
another hour
but sweetie you know fun things always
happen in the ninth inning of baseball
everyone who leaves in the you know
gotta go would you go would you go
you're out you both you and i both would
be
oh please yeah yeah and i don't say
goodbye i'm out i stand if i if i go to
any sporting event in the last two
minutes i'm at the top of the staircase
yeah waiting oh yeah
let me ask you this like in a meeting if
there was a speaker
because my sponsor always says you
always have to congratulate the speaker
or thank him right do you do it
at a 45-minute speaker meeting when
someone really puts in like it's
basically a one-act yeah yeah but if
it's a 200-seat meeting would you
no yeah i've done that before yeah and i
i don't like it
because he has to say
thank you
to so many people so his interaction
with you is so quick you know sometimes
they don't look at it they're like thank
you
and then i was like i waited come on
lock eyes
[Laughter]
come on you know what yeah probably
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know i'm not doing a jingle for this
peloton because peloton is literally the
only way i get exercise
it's the funnest way to do it peloton
the instructors are great peloton extra
instructors are highly trained fitness
pros who motivate you i need motivation